let's talk about the the twitter thing
that you know lydia just brought up
second ago we have this story from
timcast.com twitter announces new
expansion of its private information
policy the announcement has been noted
for its vague language by twitter users
so this is uh basically
media that they deem to be private
will be uh
banned they can now ban you and they say
in the rules explicitly that if you are
not abusing someone then they can still
remove you now because they have a new
rule set this will mean independent
journalists it will mean that reporters
on the ground who happen to be filming
certain activists doing something will
get all of that content removed they
then came out and said well we'll
clarify we'll clarify um
if it's a big protest or it's newsworthy
we'll consider the context what does
that mean andy knows a great example
andy noe is a journalist and the left
absolutely despises him because he
reports on what antifa and these other
individuals are doing so
naturally
twitter's probably going to say oh this
is exposing activists and it's really
dangerous because they literally in
their rules say activists dissidents
women and minorities are the most
vulnerable
now if you met for instance you went to
uh loudoun county right and you spoke
there yeah they're not going to protect
you
they're they're going to say
you know if if a video comes out of you
and you say hey look this is a private
video from an event it's really bad for
me as an activist they're going to say
shut your mouth they're gonna say oh you
don't count you're not an activist and
you know is not a journalist he doesn't
deserve any protections i kind of feel
like this is an expansion of their
policy that they informally put in place
with the hunter biden stuff because
wasn't their argument that this was
acquired through you know untoward means
or whatever like through actually
illegal ways
legally
i mean they just should have saved
everyone some time and just said future
project veritas will no longer be
allowed on the platform that would have
been more honest because if you look at
who this is going to affect it's going
to be investigative journalists right
muck breakers it's literally veritas yes
it's literally i mean they just should
have said this policy no more project
veritas videos on top of people sharing
those videos it's done that's it it's
also people are
parsing this on twitter and saying what
does this mean what about this what
about that well it's it's that's the
point the it's the ambiguity is the
point it's supposed to be vague because
then that gives them the ability to
decide so they they can just kind of
decide well yeah we're gonna get rid of
project veritas we're not gonna let
another written house situation happen
ever again they're saying uh where these
videos come out to expose the truth but
then of course because the the other
thing is well what about all these cop
videos i mean the george floyd video uh
derek chovin did not did not consent to
having that video out there but we can
we can assume that all the cop videos
are gonna still be allowed uh but
they'll just be able to decide in the
moment and that's exactly what they're
setting themselves themselves up for
it's it's the increasing movement
towards homogenizing our culture once
again so it used to be we had a few
media channels everybody listened to
walter cronkite just believed whatever
he said whether it was true or not
everyone assumed he was it was true
and then with the birth of the internet
we had all of these different voices
rising up boy did they get mad when alex
jones was getting hundreds of millions
of views we never approved this guy so
saith the establishment so they get rid
of them they get rid of milo they get
rid of laura lumer they heard of all
these undesirables
now they got to contend with the fact
that they're still dissident voices that
are doing pretty well because people
want and crave freedom and honesty and
information oh so they'll want to get
rid of us they don't they don't like
that you know we have a show where we
challenge the establishment so what
we're going to see with this with
twitter's you know policy is project
veritas gotta go andy knows reporting
gotta go if we do we did a story on uh
fouchy's uh uh the nia the niaid funding
monkey maximum pain experiments other oh
no you can't publish those photos or
that information about fauci it's
private information they will just
decide they've already done it with the
hunter biden laptop story they don't
care about hacked information tons of
hacked information has come up they
don't block it now they're just
formalizing the rule and letting you
know the end result of this is over the
next several years
eventually everyone would be watching
cnn
a lot of people say cnn's ratings are in
the gutter cnn got 100 million views on
youtube this month
we on this show i think got like 25
right tim cast all together maybe has
like 40. so it's that's great that's
awesome
cnn is being given a hundred million
views we we fight for that we we work
every day we we tell everyone we bag we
drop we get down and we say please
listener share this video because we
aren't being promoted the way cnn is by
youtube
and they get free money free promotion
you're thriving in spite of everything
that youtube it's the same thing the
daily wire you know where i work i work
at the daily wire uh we do really well
on facebook and uh the the the media is
there the corporate media is always
putting out these uh these like exposes
about look how well the daily wires do
on facebook obviously facebook uh favors
right-wing content or what look what
look what facebook is doing to help out
the daily wire it's absurd of course
we're doing well in spite of everything
facebook has done to uh to stifle it but
this is just their their way of getting
rid of the the competition they don't
like the fact that that we do the reason
why we do well is because people
actually want this content because
they're looking for just common sense
and truth and that sort of thing it may
be
that um
you know we are wading through the muck
in the mire and the the water seems to
be rising trying to hold
you know hold us back but they're losing
they're they're losing uh when i look at
how how ex explosive the daily wire has
been
like what you guys have been doing they
can't stop you
you're gonna you're gonna shatter
through that they set up this barrier
trying to hold you guys back but you're
breaking cnn is on life support it's
like they're on a gurney being wheeled
out in front of the white house and
they're like everyone's like hey look
put all the cameras on cnn right now and
it's like
it's obvious that that's a dying art
form yeah there's this episode of the
outer limits where this really old guy
you know death is trying to take him to
the other side but he keeps he's super
rich so he pays people to like keep
giving him new hearts and he's not like
a sixth heart transplant that's cnn yes
they're just like like ian explained it
but it's worse than that they're like
another thing to really kind of think
about here is that a lot of cnn viewers
are force-fed cnn people have to go out
and find alternative media people have
to go out and find tim cast daily wire
we are change and and that in itself is
a huge victory that we're still able to
survive when of course in the cyber
gulags they're literally
shoving it down your throats and people
are still spitting it out and saying
wait wait hold on there has to be
something better uh there has to be
something more nutritious for my body
and my mind out there that actually has
some semblance of truth and
responsibility in it and that's when
they find other people that and they're
making it more and more difficult for
for them to find us but people still are
yeah because i think that the corporate
media is really fighting with a free
market right now which is really
interesting to me because they're trying
to throttle it and i'm a little bit
concerned that the next step is going to
be something like a government monopoly
like that genuinely concerns me watching
the collusion between um the democrats
and the corporate media as luke it
reminds us to call it um it's very very
troubling to me to watch and see the
reflection that like the parents in
loudoun county are talking about how
this very much reminds me of the
cultural revolution in china and i can't
imagine that the government was exactly
you know easy on the media when they
were trying to compel every single
person in the country to come
conform with their will so i'm not sure
what the next step is but it's a little
a little bit unsettling yes that media
crackdown you got to watch out for that
i've explained i've explained it several
times as this there's there's this big
island run
it's just sheer cliff on all sides and
you have
people on the right side of this the the
waves crash the cliff erodes right and
and the far right falls into the ocean
what's next is conservatives the waves
crash the cliff erodes the conservatives
all fallen then you've got you know
moderate slightly center right
individuals then the centrist and what's
left is going to be
people who believe anyone to the right
of mao is far right yes that's who's
going to be left standing exactly or to
be fair a gigantic corporate you know
monolith saying you guys are useful
idiots for us we accept that well i'm a
little bit concerned because i'm gonna
make kind of an esoteric reference here
but there is a poem but i think william
butler yates where he uh it's called the
second coming and he talks about how
the worst of are full of like
this
ridiculous intention and they have a
strong desire to commit these worst acts
and the best are just like silent and he
says in that poem that the center cannot
hold that is so interesting to me
because i've heard the expression you
know if you stay in the center of the
road you get going to get run over so i
wonder if these values at the center
holds it's possible that the edges are
being whittled away enough and that
their beliefs are weak enough that
they're just gonna you know there was a
there was a left and a right in this
country
and it started to split further and
further apart there's an amazing graphic
by uh
graph by pew research where it shows
from 1994 until today how the left and
right have moved and the right has moved
like a teeny bit to the right and the
left has shot super far left
at at that point you know i always
thought it's like okay well we're really
polarized when when in reality what
actually happened is it got so far that
it broke off into two different
realities yeah and there's that's the
thing there is no there is no center or
moderate position anymore because in
between that is sort of like a an abyss
and you look at any
the the issue that i've written this
book about johnny the wallers at
johnnywalrus.com uh is is just like this
because there's a question here okay of
can a four-year-old boy uh be a girl if
he says that he is and the answer to
that question is either yes or no
there's there's no in between well i'm
kind of moderate on that um
by biology your biological sex that's
either a reality or it's not and uh so
many issues are like this now where it's
you have to you really have to choose
it's a time of choosing you have to
decide i'm i'm either on the side of
reality or not i don't think there's a
moderate position this is what's been
happening i mean this is a really good
example that there uh when you had um
who was that professor who was debating
jordan peterson nicholas matt was that
his name yeah that person so uh
this professor was in canada said
there's no such thing as biological sex
that's that's a misconception and i
would break that down but in the
interest of time i won't
there are people who genuinely say
things like that now
as we we were talking about earlier
people don't question their reality so
if you have people who are born being
told the moon is made of cheese their
whole life they would never question it
it's it's you know the interesting thing
about uh i i grew up catholic
for several years and then my family
left the church
but i actually could understand
faith-based arguments on the nature of
reality why well
there's a lot of great philosophers in
in many of these religions so when you
actually come with a really
with with an actual religion
many of them i think are kind of you
know out there some of them have very
interesting
intelligent thinkers then i look at
locism and it's just garbled nonsense
that makes no sense but
these people
act as though they're part of a giant
religion it's a non-theistic religion
now
yeah i i think i i would even draw i
don't know if this is a real
definitional distinction or not but i
like there's a difference between a
religion and a cult and um i i i would
look at
locusts or whatever we want to call them
it's more of a cult it's kind of like
scientology because the thing about a
religion say the christian religion for
example is that um it has a lot to say
about the world about human nature that
even if you're not part of that religion
you can still understand and gain
something from you don't have to be a
christian to read the gospels and and
derive something from it and find it
quite beautiful and useful uh whereas
this wocus stuff i mean i just on on my
show i read uh there was this i forget
who shared it but it was um a mass a
gender studies masters thesis that from
the university of of wisconsin milwaukee
that someone found online and they just
shared it and just the intro of it and
it's it's woke you know crt garbage but
it makes no sense at all it's totally
it's this like insular
thing where you have to be in it to even
understand what they're talking about so
if you're not with with a real religion
you can gain some wisdom from it either
you're not even if you're not in it with
the cult like scientology you have to be
in it first to uh be indoctrinated into
their kind of logic to even know what
the hell they're trying to say it's is a
good word you got to learn the
definition of before you can start to
understand the language like and one one
one phrase that was used in this thing
was it was the phrase anti-racist racist
that's just right
it means nothing it makes no sense but
you have to be first you have to be
indoctrinated into the cult first and
then you kind of can make sense of it
this is kind of what i you know i was
meaning to get to right like or trying
to explain with uh
a good example is v for vendetta love
this movie when evie goes to that
comedian's house and he shows her his
secret you know room where he's got i
think it's gay porn or something like
that yeah because he's like if the
police found out i had this yeah and uh
she also says is that a quran
she's like but you're you're not muslim
and he says i don't need to be muslim to
find its stories moving or it's imagery
beautiful or something like that and
that's that that's a great point uh i
don't think you have to believe in in
the religion to read it and understand
some of the ideas to agree or disagree
with some of these things but when i've
tried reading woke
sign like woke these you know reports or
whatever or like scientific i don't know
humanities whatever you call it academic
stuff academic studies
it's like they'll say something like
extrapolating the anti-whiteness of
white reasoning in white supremacist
agriculture through the medieval
archetypes and you're like
it doesn't mean anything it doesn't mean
yeah you need to learn the language no
no no no no no no no no no no what i'm
saying is quite literally it doesn't
mean anything and what you get are
people mindlessly saying things that
don't mean anything to each other just
to try and sound like they know more
than they do it's meant yeah it's meant
to confuse you it's meant to have you in
this state of like what's going on two
plus two equals five yes it is of course
it is yes just tell me what the even
beyond that it's it's to go like this
luke luke luke luke you know uh you you
clearly don't understand look when i
wrote my thesis on the archetypal white
supremacist anti-racist racist uh
conflating with with with antifa and the
wmic sin of northern medieval tribes
you if you don't understand that then
certainly you must step back and give me
the room and the floor to speak because
you're not an expert here
as a as an official person of color i
decline your uh
i'm mixed race
well that doesn't matter i think i'm on
the hierarchy here actually that's true
that's true so uh so
you lose i don't know if you know this
but uh the coalition for communities of
color have said that slavic people are
people of color really so blonde hair
blue eyed luke rodkowski is a person of
color poland polish porn thank you very
much i i have my card i laminated it and
i've been using it ever since so
actually for your struggles luke
thank you ian look i do defer to you on
the progressive stack because i'm
actually uh german irish british and
then part korean so i'm actually more
white and you're slavic so you're all
you know 100 percent person of color
exactly
i'll stop speaking i'll just give you
thank you very much i mean we should
call this show what it is you know the
rodowski hour but anyway right
what it is it's also screeching it's
also a lot of emotion it's also a lot of
manipulation and there's also no
redemption in this kind of church of the
cult that's being promoted on
individuals that is absolutely just
spewing nonsense and i think this
nonsense is done deliberately in order
to acquiesce the general public into
compliance into having them on their
knees literally saying yes i will obey
whatever crazy wombs you decide for me
because when you have someone at a state
where they don't even know what they
believe in you have a state where they
can be very easily controlled and
manipulated at the whim of a mob that of
course is also manipulated on social
media and um
and and weaponized in a way where it
creates people's actions to be
manipulated by them so so i think that's
an aspect here that we also should
entertain with big tech's involvement in
the kind of pushing of this cult i saw
this hilarious like meme i guess and it
said capitalism everybody is poor and a
few people are rich communism nobody
nobody is rich a few party members
control everything socialism
uh anybody can be rich but nobody is
ever poor and i was just like man these
people are insane but that's you know i
bring that up because the goal is
communism and socialism what's the
difference
honestly very little but there's a
distinction right socialism is the
economic system communism is more the
political system both are effectively
the same thing the means of production
are owned by the people what tends to
happen is the same thing powerful elites
gain control of everything and then
everyone is poor and suffers and
centralized planning doesn't work but
they use language manipulation to be
like we're not communists in socialism
no one's poor it's literally said that
the end goal of socialism is always
communism and i believe this to be the
case based on what socialism does like
it's very very similar this is how they
manipulate with language i know they're
good thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you